British Prime Minister Boris Johnson has
outlined what he's calling his final
offer to Brussels on the terms of a deal
for the UK's exit from the European
Union
Johnson was addressing his Conservative
Party's annual conference in the
northern English city of Manchester one
of the biggest stumbling blocks in
negotiations with the EU is how to
prevent a hard border between Northern
Ireland and the Republic of Ireland
Johnson said new proposals on the border
would be officially conveyed to Brussels
later this afternoon and he called them
a compromise for the UK today in
Brussels we are taping what I believe
are constructive and reasonable
proposals which provide a compromise for
both sides we will under no
circumstances have checks at or near the
border in Northern Ireland we will
we will respect the peace process and
the Good Friday Agreement ban by a
process of renewable democratic consent
by the executive and the Assembly of
Northern Ireland we will go further and
protect the existing regulatory
arrangements for farmers and businesses
on both sides of the border and at the
same time we will allow the UK whole and
entire to withdraw from the EU with
control over our own trade policy from
the start all right let's bring in our
correspondents on this story Berkut mass
is standing by for us in Manchester and
Gareth mattis is in Brussels welcome to
you both Bogard let's start with you if
we listen to what Boris Johnson just
said he didn't offer a lot of detail
when it comes to overcoming the problem
of the Irish border did he say anything
more specific other than what we just
heard
well no Sumi he was really very light on
the detail as you just said and also I
think you have to bear in mind that what
he's offering on the one hand he says
there will be no checks at only at the
border and on the other hand he promises
that the UK will leave the European
Union and the customs union completely
withdraw completely that's in itself
really a contradiction almost he hasn't
really told us how exactly he's going to
square the circle now we are hearing
that the so called final offer is being
made to Brussels later today so we will
possibly get some more details on this
but importantly here in Manchester would
the message that he was really trying to
bring across and where he was very much
supported by the party membership to say
that this is really a final offer we are
going to walk away if the EU doesn't
engage in a way that he Johnson deems
the correct way with this offer so
really saying we are going to leave and
you just have to basically take this
offer and have to help us find the
compromise and walk away with no deal
and this is where you've got the most
applause
here at the party conference when he was
asking the audience are we ready for no
deal and everybody shouted yes while his
proposals will officially be sent to the
EU this afternoon let's come to you now
Gary Boris Johnson still seems to be
trying to square this impossible circle
as we heard Birgit they say they're of
keeping the Irish border open but also
taking the entire UK out of the customs
union and the single market how do you
think Brussels is likely to react
Osumi in brussels officials are clearly
aware of the fact that there is a
concern on the part of the British
government that in case of a No Deal
practices which would it be harmful for
both sides they don't want to be
pictured as the ones who did not reach
out the hand and so that is why the word
compromise was mentioned a number of
times by the British prime minister in
that speech the only problem is that
officials here in Brussels and and
experts all what I have heard from yet I
can't see exactly where that compromise
lies because as bill get has pointed out
correctly you can't have both you can't
have no checks at the border and while
at the same time and leaving the customs
union I've traveled to Norway for
instance to take a look at a country
that is not in the customs union but in
the internal market something the Prime
Minister may envisage we all will have
to wait for the details but there is
clearly a border to Sweden which is an
EU member state so there is no example
and when the Prime Minister Boris
Johnson here says we have to trust into
technology or face a heart brexit that
is not an option that process wants to
stick to they want to be sure that the
future trade relationship ship can be
guaranteed and therefore there is this
idea of a transition period and a
backstop in case no solution can be
found
okay what about Ireland gehrig how much
of a say will it have and whether to
accept any compromise offer from the UK
are the unity on the part of the 27
member states including Ireland was was
very was very strong in the past and it
will remain strong that's what I've
heard from from member states so don't
expect Island to be pressed by either
Germany France or any other of the 27 to
accept any deal that would harm
internal border that currently is an
open border barricade coming back to you
in Manchester is Forrest Johnson
actually interested in the EU accepting
his latest proposals or is he really set
on a No Deal brexit well it was
interesting I was speaking to some EU
diplomats here at the conference and
asking them how serious are Boris
Johnson's proposals what do they think
about it even though we don't know the
details yet but there have been some
rumours in EU circles and that wasn't
exactly a ringing endorsement it was
more okay well we have to live in hope
that he really does want a deal but it
wasn't very enthusiastic and of course
there has been a lot of speculation that
he's really rallying the country also
behind the idea of no deal and that he
just wants to shift the blame but well
it remains to be seen how when we get
the the final offer the so-called final
avoid get the details how seriously they
will be taken by Brussels alright Berkut
mass for us in Manchester and Gareth
mattes in Brussels thank you both